yeah the medals just keep coming if
you've just woken up we've got more
success in the aquatic center here in
tokyo
overnight and it's another tom in tokyo
tom dean from maidenhead
who just beat his teammate duncan scott
in the 200 meter freestyle what a
thrilling finish it was just a couple of
tenths of a second between them but they
take gold and silver
in that event and that is the first time
that has happened since 1908
tom dean from maidenhead in berkshire
trained down in bath
and really a great story because he had
covered twice
in the last 12 months and he had six or
seven weeks disrupted in an olympic year
in the run-up to these olympics
that training of course is crucial to as
any athlete
will tell you and to have that kind of
disruption he was
motivated by his coach who said look
don't let this hold you back you can
come back from this and
boy has he done that in the pool today
winning gold and
we saw of course duncan scott as well
scotland's first medal by our
calculations
of glaswegian and also trained in
ayrshire as well so big celebrations
up in scotland today on the back of that
silver medal in the pool
on top of a gold medal that hasn't
happened since 1908
for team gb tom i understand of course
the olympics are all about overcoming
adversity but you know overcoming a
puncture
during the cycling section of the
triathlon that's quite something
it really was very exciting finnish very
strong women's triathlon team
here forget great britain and it was
georgia taylor brown from manchester
who really pushed hard and
hit some kind of pothole she's just been
telling us that meant that her bike
tyre was damaged she could hear the hiss
of the air coming out she thought it
might be her brakes but then
she was running on a flat she had to
make that decision did she stop and
change the tire and potentially cost
herself a minute
or did she push on on a flat tire
effectively just running on the frame of
that wheel and she did the latter
she managed to get rounds on the bike
into the run and she really attacked the
run hard around
the edge of tokyo bay here and ended up
with a silver medal
and she's just been telling us here just
what that means all the hours of
dedication how
she dreamed as a young girl of going to
the olympics and now she's here and done
it and won a silver medal it's a great
story
tom for those of us lucky enough to be
able to head home after work and sit
down in front of the telly and watch the
rest of the olympics
what more do i have to look forward to
today
well i think the medal rush may well
continue because
team gb are on fire at the moment aren't
they and that kind of ripples through
the camp you can see the way that
they've been celebrating the medals in
the various sports that have come
through of course we had those great
moments with adam peaty and tom daley
yesterday and
tom pig [ __ ] in the mountain biking but
today watch out for charlotte dujardan
you'll remember her name from the
dressage
equestrian events the horse dancing as
everyone calls it colloquially and
she is going for her third successive
gold
medal today she won gold in london in
rio can she do it here in tokyo
after all the disruption that all these
athletes have been through there are
some extraordinary stories coming to the
fore
of just how they've pushed through all
those difficulties through lockdown
through covid
and have come here and taken their
moments and made all that
heart a campaign along the way well
worth it